I was reading that you guys just checked  out uh Britney Spears as shown from  Hollywood we did Kevin and I went out  there with our managers to do some recon  for a possible residency so we wanted to  go see the production see the show catch  up with our old friend Brittany and she  was amazing as usual she's such a  amazing performer she's so sweet  she hasn't she's not changed a bit  I was a fan just being there and then  she pulled me onstage and did what she  did with me which was which was fun my  wife was actually super jealous that she  that she wasn't the one that got spanked  telling me the Backstreet Boys might  have a residency in Vegas we are talking  about it so we are looking into it right  now and we'll see we'll see what happens  right now we're actually back in the  studio making our ninth album so if  anything transpires it'll probably come  after our brand-new tour so as well as  I'm doing my break for solo projects and  there's a lot of things going on this  year